una placa en honor a un glaciar que ya
no existe a las generaciones futuras
aquí existió el glaciar a lo loco y
retrocedió hasta desaparecer en 2018
en las próximas décadas los glaseadas
mexicanos desaparecerán
irremediablemente según un reciente
estudio de la revista nation miles de
glaciares en el mundo podrán correr la
misma suerte con imágenes satelitales
estudiaron alrededor de 220.000
glaciares del mundo excluyendo los de
groenlandia y la antártica desde 2000
hasta 2019 su conclusión es que estas
capas de hielo se están derritiendo
rápidamente alterando el nivel del mar y
los ecosistemas en múltiples dimensiones
a escala global el principal causante es
la temperatura
y es difícil de separar el hecho de que
la temperatura está causando el deshielo
con el hecho de que los humanos están
por mucho causando un incremento de la
temperatura
durante el periodo estudiado los
glaciares perdieron un promedio de 267
giga toneladas de hielo al año la nasa
calcula que sólo una gigatonelada de
hielo equivaldría a un bloque de 341
metros de altura sobre el central park
de nueva york una vez se derrite es casi
imposible recuperar un glaciar se
requieren décadas o siglos para acumular
las lluvias de un año tras otro y contar
con las temperaturas óptimas para que
esa agua se congele así que no estamos
en un punto donde la discusión sea
acerca de hacer crecer los glaciares o
mantenerlos exactamente como están ahora
estamos en un punto en el que estamos
tratando de mantener tanto hielo como
sea posible y realmente disminuir la
tasa de pérdida en un estudio similar
que sintetizó más de 100 modelos por
computadora generados por institutos de
todo el mundo el diario británico the
gardian concluyó que un 10 por ciento
del hielo glaciar se perderá de aquí a
2050 incluso si se cumplen los objetivos
del acuerdo de parís